oh this is a mistake
so i'm about to embark on a discussion
that i have
really really really
not wanted to have and that is in
regards to
amber heard so before i get
too far into the weeds on this at all
here's something i want to make
absolutely clear at the front end i
am not here to litigate or debate
what went on between amber hurt and
johnny depp
that's not what this video is about
please please do not
devolve my comment section into an
argument or
shouting at people over what they should
or shouldn't believe
about the situation between the two of
them that is not what i'm here to talk
about today
don't turn it into that
i will touch briefly
on some of the things that have gone on
but i want to have the conversation that
is usually what i want to have
when i talk about these things like when
i talk about joss whedon
like when i talked about gina chrono i
want to talk about how the situation is
similar to
or different from circumstances that
we've already
seen where someone involved in a
creative work
seems to have basically a dark cloud
around them
and to then talk about why this is or
isn't playing out the way that we've
seen it play out
in other cases that's the conversation
i will be having today okay
okay at time of recording
and lord help me if this changes between
when i
shoot this and when it goes up but at
time of recording
the rumor went around earlier today
that amber heard had been fired from
aquaman
2. that rumor at time of recording
has largely been debunked by more
reliable sources
than were the source of the original
rumor that she had been
fired so at present at time of recording
she does appear to still be
working on aquaman 2.
here's the thing even if that changes
ideally after i get this video out but
even if it changes before i get this
video live
i still think i have stuff to talk about
here that is going to be relevant to a
discussion regardless of what the
ultimate outcome of whether she does or
does not stay on the project
is so
super briefly amber heard and johnny
depp
are ex-spouses they were married they
had a
very tumultuous marriage and
since their breakup there has been
continued litigation on multiple fronts
between the two of them between um
johnny depp
and newspapers in the uk which was
something i actually talked about over
on the council of geeks
and now there's more litigation that is
scheduled to come up between herd and
depth there were recordings that came
out
that really muddied the waters versus
what was sort of the
by some people at least the accepted
narrative of what had gone out
nobody looks good in this and again
i am not here to say who is right
who is wrong who is victim who is abuser
that's not the conversation today
but know that there is certainly a very
vocal contingent of people who are very
angry at amber heard and there is
reason to believe that
she had an abusive relationship
with johnny depp not solely as a victim
and possibly not as a victim at all
again
don't d this is not the debate i'm just
laying the groundwork for what the
temperature
of the room is where all this is
happening
so there have been calls for some time
to get amber heard removed from her role
as mera
from the dc universe of films at this
point she has played the character
twice once in justice league and once
in um aquaman i believe she was brought
back for some of the reshoots done
on zack snyder's cut i didn't bother to
double check that though because it's
not
super relevant to the conversation i'm
going to have
so here's mainly what i want to talk
about
how is this different from or similar to
the stuff we've seen going on well
honestly in the last few weeks but also
the last few years
let's pull back and look at a bigger
picture
because on the surface this would appear
to be
another case of a person
involved in a major franchise who
there appear to be issues with a
significant part of the audience appears
to be
turning on them and the question becomes
whether the
people behind the film keep them on
or cut them loose and so far at time of
recording
warner brothers appears to be keeping
amber heard on board
though even that there may be some uh
dispute about because
another rumor that's come out since the
fire no not fired thing
happened is there is some reporting that
amber heard
believes that warner brothers may have
leaked to that rumor in the first place
basically to gauge reaction now
i'm not going to put a ton of weight
behind that notion
either that it happened or that she
believes that it happened because
again sourcing on that is not great and
this is part of why i really have not
wanted to talk about amber heard
at all because the rumor mill is insane
on this and there's a lot of
confirmed insanity but it spirals into
nonsense very quickly
but let's compare it to some of the
stuff that's gone on lately
let's start with joss whedon now joss
whedon
while technically not fired official
word is he
chose to leave his upcoming hbo show the
nevers
because of creative differences it
seems fairly clear at this point that
even if he left voluntarily it was with
the knowledge that they were probably
going to ask him to leave
later anyways so with whedon the issue
has been
his on-set behavior the way he has
treated his actors his fellow writers
and those who work underneath him on set
so
wheaton is probably the most
toxic right now and i don't mean
necessarily in terms of behavior i mean
in terms of
he's kind of radioactive the idea of
working with him right now
because not only has the public
perception of him turned
very harshly it's because of the way he
conducts himself
in the work environment so even if
the public decided they were kind of
over it just
in in the mechanisms of hollywood
most people are going to go i don't want
to work with that guy
i heard how he treated people so he's
really kind of untouchable right now
then there is gina carano now
did a whole video explaining this but
short version for my perspective
i do not believe that carano was
uh taken off of the mandalorian
fired is i don't think it's inaccurate
technically they chose not to renew her
contract
to bring her back for future seasons and
spin-off work
but that there i do not believe
was a moral judgment because of the
sorts of stuff she had been tweeting
which as a reminder
there was some um mockery of the use of
putting pronouns in uh in bios on
twitter
that caused the kerfuffle there was some
anti-mask stuff there was some other
stuff later that
was a very messy um invoking of things
that had gone
on with um the jews in the lead-up to
the holocaust that rubbed a lot of
people the wrong way
but i still do not believe that she was
let go because of an actual moral
judgment of anything of anything that
she said
but simply because she kept causing
bad headlines she kept coming up in the
news cycle and every time she did
it was mandalorian star controversy
so it was repeated bad press so she was
gone
now her choice at this point has been to
hook up with ben shapiro and work with
him
on a film project which is whatever you
think of ben shapiro is going to be very
small potatoes compared to working with
lucasfilm and disney so but
she is certainly capable of working with
people
who don't feel that the pr around her is
going to hurt
their particular brand and ben shapiro's
brand again whatever you think of him
isn't really going to be hurt by most of
the stuff that is circled around her
so that's where she is at the ding for
her
was repeatedly causing bad press
so amber heard the issues around
her are not on set behavior so we're not
looking at a joss whedon's situation
you would think that it would be
equivalent to gina carano though
since these stories about amber heard
keep
coming up they've been coming up in news
cycles for
about a year fairly reliably
there is a similarity but there's also a
fairly key difference
which is that the things coming up about
amber heard
are basically new details about
the same stuff so
from the perspective of a studio head
or an agent she's not
repeatedly getting into trouble
she got into trouble and
the details and the reasons why and the
information behind why
people are turning on her more is coming
out but the incidents
aren't happening anew so with carano
there's fairly reliable reporting that
after her first few issues on twitter
and causing controversy
she was talked to by the people running
the mandalorian
and her agents you have to stop doing
this and then she kept doing it
and so they let her go again both
um lucasfilm and her rep agency dropped
her
amber heard isn't repeatedly doing the
same stuff
so it is slightly different they can't
really shake a finger at her and said we
told you to behave because she's not
committing
new offenses we're finding out new
information
about older stuff that happened and
largely all circling the same
handful of incidents with johnny depp so
it isn't
quite the same and again i'm not passing
moral judgment on whether they should or
should not
ditch amber heard i'm only talking about
why this is playing out a little bit
different
the other thing to keep in mind is that
there are some people out there who like
to talk about
hollywood like it's a monolith who will
look at something like this and go
well they fire gina carano why won't
they fire amber heard well
because they're not employed by the same
people
gina carano worked for lucasfilm owned
by disney
amber heard's major franchise is
dc owned by warner brothers these are
completely different companies
so you can't really be going well
they did this to this person let's use
it it's not the same people
it's the same industry they all know
each other but
it's not actually the same people so
even if we narrow it down within warner
brothers
this is where johnny depp gets wrote
back in because johnny depp
was let go from the third fantastic
beasts movie which already has its own
issues having to do with jk rowling
and the tarnishing of her name but i'm
definitely not getting back into
that right now but he was let go out of
his role
as grindelwald who was actually the
titular character
in the second of those films he was
ultimately replaced by mads mikkelsen
and again i did talk about that in the
video i mentioned
earlier that i did over on the break
room where it wasn't
necessarily that there was a firm
determination
that johnny depp did or didn't do what
he's been accused of doing around amber
heard
but the issue was he lost a suit where
he tried to sue
a british tabloid and he lost
and the way that the law the libel laws
work in england
for him to lose that's a bad
look because it's a lot easier to sue
people for
libel and definite defamation in england
than it is in the us
so for him to take that suit and to lose
that that was kind of a bad sign and
that was probably why he was let go
again
i suspect not because of a moral
judgment of what he did
but this brings me back to well
now we are talking within the same
company because harry potter
is being handled under warner brothers
dc
is being handled under warner brothers
why aren't they treating these people
the same
because certainly the look for warner
brothers right now
and it's not a good look is that they
are
siding with death with herd against depp
that's not a good look but there's a
couple of things to keep in mind
the first is even though this is the
same parent company
these are different divisions the
producers and
head studio people in charge of
fostering
the harry potter franchise are not the
same people
in charge of them fostering the dc
franchise now they
answer to the same people but the odds
of the absolute
top brass getting involved on this are
incredibly rare
and very very unlikely generally it's
going to be the head of that immediate
division
who is making their call as to whether
or not it is a good or bad idea to
continue keeping this person in
and the the person heading uh
harry potter doesn't have to care that
what they decide to do with depp
is consistent with what whoever is
currently making the
hiring firing choices on the dc the dc
side of things
decides to do with amber heard they
don't have to be consistent
again not the same people
however falling under the same umbrella
of the same parent company
it is not a great look and actually
let's touch back on the rumors that went
around it'll be
yesterday if i get this out as quickly
as i intend to
so what was odd and this is one of the
things that debunked it but i'm just
going to entertain this as a thought
exercise
really briefly what was odd about that
rumor was that
the rumor wasn't that she was fired
because
of anything related to depp the rumor
was that she was fired because she
failed her physical
now i'm not going to say that kind of
thing never happens
but one it almost
never happens to stars the size of her
now heard is hardly the biggest name
in aquaman but she is a name at this
point someone with the amount of
clout professional clout that she would
have
wouldn't be fired for failing a physical
and
let's be clear failing and physical in
this case basically
means and like the rumors even got into
detail she wasn't in shape to do the
stunts and had put on weight
so this was part of the debunking now
again
people can be let go for that but that's
usually
your lower rung c list supporting
characters or your extras
get dumped for that your your name
in the opening credits stars don't get
dropped for that
and it would be as bad a look as it is
right now for warner brothers to
continue to employ her when they got rid
of depp
it would be a very bad look for them to
basically fire a woman for gaining
weight
that ain't a good look either
but there's one other thing that i'm not
sure if people are accounting for that i
think is probably in play
as to what well i say one other two
other things
um but here's the first of two that i
don't see people accounting for when
they talk about
why warner brothers is or isn't or
should or shouldn't get rid of amber
heard
the first is warner brothers doesn't
want their own version of james gunn
on their hands so let's go over that
real quick
quick reminder james gunn was all set up
to do
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 for marvel
over at disney
he was let go and cut out of that when
there was an online campaign over some
old tweets that he
had done where he made light of things
like child abuse now
disney acted very quickly and in a way
fairly predictable this is
bad press it is in direct contradiction
to the kind of image we try and have as
a company
you're gone the thing was disney really
ended up with egg on their face over
that
because well for a number of reasons the
first is
it became clear fairly soon after he was
fired it was fairly easy to track back
that this
wasn't really a a sincere ground
swell of people who did not approve of
james gunn it was a coordinated effort
by people who disliked his political
opinions
who dug up old tweets of his that he had
actually not only were they years old
but he had acknowledged in the past
apologized for in the past at this point
had years
of not repeating that behavior and in
fact of disavowing it
so it really ended up being bad for
disney because they basically
gave into a fake outrage campaign
and fired someone for stuff that they
would have been well aware of or at
least should have been well aware of
at the time that they hired him and
stuff that all evidence indicated he had
gotten
better about and grown and was no longer
like that
and so they lost him
lost a lot of time they did ultimately
bring him back and he will make
guardians of the galaxy volume 3
not before warner brothers snatched him
up to do suicide
the suicide squad first so disney lost
uh time and turnaround time on getting a
new guardians of the galaxy
and they lost that time to their direct
rival
in terms of superhero franchises so that
was a real
that was a real bad look for disney
disney came out
really bad for that deal and so warner
brothers or
anybody any studio is going to be
really wary about letting
someone go first stuff done
offset some time ago now
this is not this is not me equating
tweets that james gunn did with the
behavior that it is believed and
suspected and possible that amber heard
has engaged in
i'm not equivocating those things at all
but i'm
saying that the events that happen with
james gunn are going to make
the people who make the hiring of hiring
decisions
wary of being too quick to
fire in a case like amber heard
where even though the actions are very
different on paper
the amount of time that has gone on
since it happened
the fact that it is not directly related
to on-job
uh behavior and that it just seems to be
the same things coming up around older
stuff
is gonna make them at least slightly
wary that they're gonna make the same
kind of mistake disney
did now that's not to say that they may
not
eventually make the decision to cut her
loose there does seem to be a pretty
significant amount of support
for that idea but there is one other
thing related to that i'll come back to
that in a minute
but at the very least something like
james gunn happening to disney
would give them reason to go about this
slowly
as opposed to swiftly
now that last thing that i set aside
there's a difference in audience
to be considered and what i mean by that
is and i'll even try and limit this
within just what's going on at warner
brothers let's set
disney aside for for a bit
the audience for harry potter
is much more heavily female is much more
heavily
liberal-leaning for the most part
is going to be much less tolerant to a
man
accused of abusing a woman so
i strongly suspect part of the calculus
for ditching depth but being slower to
and possibly not at all ditching a herd
is that the audience for harry potter is
going to be
far less likely to tolerate the
presence of depp or at least the the
studio heads believe that
and they would have reason to than
the dc audience is
likely to not tolerate amber heard
because well what has dc
been dealing with release
the snyder cut
the response from people who are
passionate about dc
has been stop interfering
has been to the studio heads stop
stepping in
give us what we wanted in the first
place
now you can make an argument that the
people who want the center cut don't
actually care about amber heard and i'd
be prepared to agree with that
but that's enough reason to muddy the
waters to think that
for as many people as have signed online
petitions to have amber heard fired and
like let's also be really clear
nobody cares about online petitions
like nobody does but
there are a significant number of names
on it but there is really no reason to
believe
as much as the petition signers would
want us to believe but there is
absolutely no reason to believe
that every signature on that petition is
a ticket sale
lost because there is a very good chance
that an
awful lot of people who are very angry
at amber heard
don't care about the dc movies whereas
what at this point is the proven
passionate audience
for the dc movies especially in the wake
of the snyder cut stuff
they care about not
having things interfered with now again
that's not me saying if somebody wanted
the snyder cut they wouldn't want her
fired no
individuals will vary people will have
their own points of view
i'm not trying to say what other people
do or don't believe
but i'm saying from a demographic
perspective from the perspective
of somebody trying to run the numbers
because that every time
is what i come back to it is about
the money people
are running numbers and calculus to try
and figure out
what is the damage if we ditch her
what is the damage if we keep her
because there's going to
at this point there's damage either way
what i think
is um very very likely is
if amber hurt is kept on for aquaman 2 i
do not expect her to come back again i
do not expect her to show up in aquaman
3 if that happens
i do not expect her to show up in any
more team-up movies if and when those
happen
so ultimately look it's just a mess
warner brothers is not in a comfortable
position right now
there is no clear good choice for them
to make right now
under the circumstances they are in
which
you know is why the rumors are able to
fly
as wildly and as quickly as they
currently are
because they can get rid of amber heard
if they're going to do that it would be
in their best interest to have a
contract violation
which is where something like the
supposed failing of the physical rumor
came from
but if they were to fire the her for
that specifically bad look
and also as i said there's the potential
risk
that they're giving in to a hate mob for
something that
most people wouldn't want them to give
on in on which is what happened with
james
gunn and then on the other hand
they have the fact that johnny depp was
let go
from a film division within the same
company
and a lot of people are throwing a lot
of support behind him
and if they continue to employ her
that's not a good look
warner brothers has no great options
here it's a question of what does more
damage and the answer
right now is not super clear
as to what does more damage which i
suspect is why they are
kind of sitting on it and will probably
continue to sit on it
i wouldn't be shocked
if what they decide to do is to
basically
let things move forward and see if they
either calm down
or get worse if they get
worse they may in fact do what they did
with johnny depp
johnny depp had started filming
fantastic beasts three
they had to get rid of him they're gonna
have to reshoot his scenes
that is possible that they could do that
with amber heard
and i wouldn't be surprised that if if
she ends up getting let go
it ends up happening part way into the
filming because
things get worse
but the other thing about waiting is
maybe
things quiet down or at the very least
fail to escalate any further than they
have
in which case they ride her out this one
film on her contract and don't renew
and move on from there
because while i don't doubt there are
people who will make the decision
to not see aquaman 2 because of amber
heard's involvement
much like the people
like me who made the choice
to not see the mandalorian two at the
time it came out
because of some of the people involved
in
disney doesn't give a crap we aren't
that many
and some people will choose not to see
aquaman two if she's in it
warner brothers doesn't give a crap you
aren't that many
i'm sorry you're not boycotts don't work
they never work but
bad press is bad press and if that picks
up enough
or is persistent enough
that might do it but as of right now we
don't know
and i don't think we will know for a
little while
of course i could be wrong about that
things could have already changed
between when i shot this and
when i released it as i said at the
front end
but that's where we are right now
this stuff is a mess
and as much as i don't actually really
like talking about it all that much
the part of me that can't stop myself is
because
i find it interesting to look at the way
the machinery works
and the way the computations of
hollywood
deal with these things when they come up
and the ways that small
differences change the outcomes the
small differences between
james gunn joss whedon gina carano
amber heard johnny depp the small
differences in each case
resulting in different outcomes i do
find that interesting and it is
something i think is worth talking about
i still don't really like talking about
it because it means i have to dip my
toes into some
insanely toxic and divisive subjects in
order to
do it but you know
that's the risk i run
that's it for this one folks i have a
patreon
if you enjoyed this video and what i do
or if you want to do something nice for
me for my birthday which is later this
month
that's actually the present i would like
the most
failing that i do have on amazon and
etsy wish list down in the description
as well as my p.o box if you
want to send me something that isn't off
either of those
but other than me trying to get people
to
buy me stuff please
other than that whatever your thoughts
are
as long as it isn't arguing over what
did or didn't happen between johnny depp
and amber heard
drop them down in the comments and let's
talk about it the usual stuff aside from
that
like share subscribe
but uh you don't have to do any of it
end of the day folks
you are the council i just run the
meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]